وقف المساعدات من قبل عدد من الدول
الغربيه مثل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
والمانيا وفنلندا وايطاليا
لانر في هذا التوقيت ل كما قيل للاشتباه
بضلوع عدد من موظفي الانر في هجمات السابع
من اكتوبر مع العلم ان الانروا تخدم
ملايين الفلسطينيين ليس في قطاع غزه فقط
ولكن في مختلف
المناطق
انا ارى هذا شكلا من اشكال العقاب الجماعي
لشعب غزه ولشعب فلسطين وايضا هي عقوبه
جماعيه للعاملين في الونر
والابطال الذين ضحوا بحياتهم ويجاز
بحياتهم للقيام بعمل لا يقوم به غيرهم
للاسف هناك تداعيات ان هذه القضيه تثار
فورا بعد حكم محكمه العدل الدوليه بوجود
احتمال كبير بارتكاب جريمه جريمه اباده
وايضا الادعاء
بان هؤلاء الذين متهمون بهذه الامور تاتي
الاتفاع اتهامات فورا بعد اصدار المحكمه
لموقفها وفيتم وقف التمويل وبذلك هذا
العمل الذي ينقذ حياه الناس ستكون له
تداعيات في غضون ايام من التقارير التي
نراها يفترض ان الانرو ستقوم بتحقيق هل
نتوقع ان تكون هناك نتيجه لهذا التحقيق في
وقت سريع وبالتالي تنتفي الحجه لدى هؤلاء
الذين يقطعون الدعم عن الانرو وموظفيها
وعن ملايين
الفلسطينيين
علينا ان نرى ماذا ستسفر عنه التحقيقات
ولكن سواء ان كشف التحقيق عن ان العاملين
في اون وان لهم علاقه بحماس او غيرها تبقى
حقيقه ان الاونر كوكه دوليه لا يمكن ان
تعاقب بسبب افعال قله ولان كثير من الناس
حياتهم تعتمد على هذه المؤسسه في غزه نعم
وانت تتحدث عن حياه الناس وانت المقرر
للامم المتحده المعني بالحق في السكن
موضوع السكن هذا كيف يمكن ان يتاثر بنوايا
اسرائيل تحدث عنها كثيرون في انشاء منطقه
عازله في قطاع غزه بعد تشريد من بها وم
ومنعهم من العوده الى مساكنهم
اعتقد ان ما نراه
للاسف وهي محاوله اخرى لسرقه الارض
والاستيلاء عليها من جانب اسرائيل المنطقه
العازله ليست فكره
جديده طبعا هم يفرضون مثل هذا
النوع في ناق حيث يسمونها مناطق محرومه و
محظوره على الدخول اليها
مثلا ينثرون فيها الاسمده الكيمياويه
وسوائل ومكافحه الحشرات
لاتلاف المحاصيل الزراعيه وايضا هم بذلك
يمنعون الناس من العايش فيها لكن هذه
المنطقه العازله اسوا من تلك محاولات
لانهم يتحدثون عن منطقه عرضها 1000 متر و
وستخف كثيرا من طول الحدود التي تمتد الى
36 كيلومترا وقد ترقى الى كونها 16 بال في
من مساحه
غزه الشعب الفلسطيني له حق المصير وايضا
الاله منحهم حق ارضهم تلاكي ارضهم
والقانون الدولي يمنحهم ذلك وهي ممارسه
ممنوعه و محظوره وفقا للقانون الدولي